so i have a um
sorry
i have a correction i did make a mistake
it is it was sonia sotomayor on the
supreme court who asked gorsuch to wear
a mask i said it was stephen breyer
um stephen breyer
i said he no it was but same difference
if you're around
my point my point was if you're around
an 83 year old
that's what my grandchildren say to me
oh right they don't want to visit me
anymore because they're afraid of
infecting me right but you look healthy
as a horse i'm much healthier than they
are exactly
you know when i didn't
i didn't get to this in the show
but one of the things in david
leonhardt's article i read about this
week that i thought was so sad
was that he made the point that older
people are the ones who should be more
scared of the virus and it's the reverse
it's the younger people they have so
scared the kids they've raised them
they've cuddled them they've helicopter
parent and they've bulldozed parented
them to the point where they're afraid
of their own shadow they have like a
minuscule possibility unless you're
having some yes people with
comorbidities do but mostly i mean
you've got the good immune system just
to read these statistics about a quarter
of the 18 to 34 year old being very
worried very worried oh [ __ ] grow a pair
if they if they go to
if they go to college on the east or
west coast
they have booster requirements they have
incredible restrictions i mean imagine
anyone in this country between the ages
of 16 and 23 who've had to go through
this like the normal stuff of
adolescence and youth you've just had
you know
when my parents died especially my
mother
i was very happy that she never knew
what i was doing in the streets in
brooklyn where i was growing up right
because the first the fundamental rule
of playing in the streets was that you
should never have adults around right
and you know
now
they want you to come watch them play
and and and and the parents can be very
destructive watching their own kids play
and and you know what i what i used to
love about growing up in the 40s in
brooklyn was that we went out and we
came back when it was dark and it was
time to have dinner
and if my mother ever knew what i was
doing and i didn't do anything terribly
dangerous i'm not talking about you know
doing anything that was really
but we were out in the empty lots we
climbed on garage roofs we sure you know
we were i mean
that's that's what and and and and
you know there was this wonderful book
that was written in the i think in the
in the late 50s called where did you go
out
what did you do
nothing
and it was about
you know it was about kids
they ought to be required meeting the
required reading now you know when when
my kids grew up
you took them to the to the playgrounds
and you didn't leave them let them play
you sat there on the benches and if one
kid got into a scrap with another kid
the mothers jumped up and mediated the
dispute
sometimes also have ordinances that it's
actually illegal for your kids under a
certain age to walk to school on their
own
yeah i mean it's literally it's just
really that bad i mean i used to walk to
school from age five all day and you
would be arrested for it yeah i mean if
they see a kid walking alone it's like a
crisis now crisis well when i was a kid
that most abductions of children are by
their relatives
and custody disputes they imagine that
every kid is being followed by a clown
with his dick out i mean
[Applause]
but yeah i mean i i was always kind of i
mean i wasn't the perfect thing but i
was kind of you weren't no
it wasn't bad but i was kind of proud
that i always
protected my parents like from the stuff
you're talking about and i did a little
things a little worse i mean when i
started in comedy you know i was living
in new york i had a shitbox apartment
but it wasn't cheap nothing is in new
york and they never really asked me they
must have known there's no money in
comedy at the beginning
they never like asked me and i didn't
tell and i didn't ask them for money but
i was selling pot
you know
you know that's that's how i live it's a
good idea not to tell your parents no
and i just write it was like don't ask
don't tell and that was well you know it
was like worse it was like cursing
everybody was afraid
as their parents found out that they
cursed when they were out in the street
oh [ __ ] yeah and and
and i i always knew that i knew earlier
i figured out what the rule was the rule
was is that your parents could curse
and you could curse but you must never
curse in the presence of each other
right there that was the rule don't
forget the streams i never heard it
expressed that you're so right
you should hang out with me more i would
love to hang out with you more i told
you you're a hero of mine um but you're
right you know i'm sure my par we just
didn't do it in front of each other
that's right and if you did everybody
would be mortified like oh my god he's
learning about these words learning
about these words i used to you know i
was a
language it was a separate language for
us
everybody knew those words the
best most honest discussion ever had
with my father was when i was in college
and i was home for like the summer or
something and i'd come in late being
stoned and he'd had three martinis
and then we kind of talked you know
okay well i got stoned with eggplants
those are the questions now uh
what does it say matt about gen x that
the most likely candidates for 2024 are
two guys over the age of 75. i guess
they mean biden and trump is biden going
to run again let's get to that one first
if they wheel him out i gotta suppose
he's he's supposed to both of them both
of them to be clear a lot of wheeling
and these they'll be in gurneys both of
them well they will no i think i think
to the questioner's point and it's a
good one is that it's yet another reason
why gen x rules is because we never
really liked politics to begin with
never got into it overly much and the
most gen x politician out there is a guy
who started off interesting but has
serially embarrassed himself beto
o'rourke um like with every skateboard
run to losing whatever his latest uh
position is in in texas um we're on to
other things i think that's great but
let's not be ageist about this like it's
not right to judge people there are
people a hundred
in this world who are still working the
fields look at this how old are you
how old am i i don't know like
i'm almost 84. 84. okay
and you don't you don't want to play
one-on-one basketball oh i would say
that to you i'll play one-on-one with
you absolutely you won't last i
guarantee really let's [ __ ] do it all
right on television we can do it right
you're just gonna punch it
and even the applause i find patronizing
like oh
you're still here
for you
it's like it's like [ __ ] you
well you know when i was a kid nobody
lived past 62.
i didn't know anybody i mean
if you said you were 85 that was like
now i open up the old bits every day in
the times right and um um you know if
you're not interested
but everybody is older than i am
okay but i mean there's something about
it's like it's like the way you talk the
way you move your energy
your acumen nothing about you suggests
a specific age other than you're
obviously a mature man
but i mean i don't know why you couldn't
be president i don't even i don't
right it's it's it's a fragrance but i
know why my my
dad who is your age shouldn't be
president for example but that's your
dad it's a case-by-case basis and with
the case of biden in the case of trump
right well trump was crazy before he was
old yeah okay that's i mean he has so
many old is the least of his problems i
agree
no it is
he does not
i mean that is one of uh trump's
great weapons that he has going for him
is he doesn't come across as old he's a
robust henry viii kind of you know just
strutting
he just you know you see him and you
don't think old you think nuts and oh a
man who became a platinum blonde in his
70s like that's cooker are you eating
that hamburger right you don't think
as he has two portions of ice cream
everybody else gets one that kind of
[ __ ] fiona you started working as a
young great segways here
as a young teenager to like me selling
pot no
as a young teenager to
help support your family
what do you think is the best way to
instill a strong worth at work
ethic among young people today well
definitely getting a job when you're 11.
honestly right
right
i mean the problem actually um you know
right now is of course gets back to you
all of your rules and regulations and
you know i i guess that's what you know
back in the day we tried to stop people
from working at 11 12 13. well that we
should yeah we did yeah but definitely
having a job early on is a great thing
to do i think with covid
all the jobs uh that kids have of you
know dried up i mean
well delivering newspapers is also hard
when you're getting in them on your
phone i did them all that's a bit
difficult
people's phones and absolutely
mowing lawns shoveling driveways
that's what my parents thought i was
living on when i was selling pot
boy that that lawnmower money really
where did you get the pot to sell
let's talk about that over basketball
thank you everybody
you